Portland Oregon hi Lisette welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show for taking my call
how are you better than I deserve what's
up about estate planning so I have a 20
year old 28 year old brother I'm 26 my
little brother is from we're all from
the same parents when my brother my
little brother was born I told my mom
and dad that you know I want him to have
a will saying indicating would take
custody just in case something bad would
happen
I didn't want that to be something that
would be struggling in court for and it
was understood that they would want me
to take custody just because of though I
fell and my brother has taken but
recently I found that they still haven't
done that and I was just kind of
wondering two things one I'm on baby
step one should I be prioritizing saving
money so that I could pay for an
attorney to write that up for them or
and two is there some kind of biblical
thing that I can show my mother because
that's one of the things she said
recently she's like I wasn't paying
about and I don't really think that it's
necessary like we're gonna live a long
life and I guess the whole purpose of it
but you just never know we're gonna live
a long life so we don't need a will
wasn't the Holy Spirit those last
night's pizza
that's absurd that's absurd
the mind of man plans his ways the Lord
directs his steps don't build a tower
without first counting the cost lest you
get halfway up and you're unable to
finish and all who see you begin to mock
you and say this man began to build and
was unable to finish we're here for just
a vapor these are scriptures that say do
a will don't play the Christian card and
cop out of doing stuff you're supposed
to take care of your family
that's ridiculous
I'm okay with offending her that's
because that's crazy bones I mean really
mom come on
your job is to take care of this kiddo
and you want one of your other kiddos to
do it and yet you're really not gonna
write it down because you've been
praying about it and you're gonna live a
long time really famous last words
oh my gosh no no no no no no no now it
doesn't take an attorney and no you
don't need to pay for it you they need
to pay for it they need to do it
yesterday have them jump on mama bear
calm where we're using who are using for
online wills now I can do it for about
50 bucks
this has anything to do with money this
has got to do with their being lame oh
okay you need to be nice you need to be
nicer than I am because I'm not their
kid but that that you can go in and just
go mom if you dad dad help me with mom
here she's doing that Christian thing
that ain't Christian so mom we got it we
got to work through this because if you
want me to take care of kiddo I need
this in writing like now tap out and
somebody else gonna take care of the kid
oh if you're not going to do business
right you got to do business right you
got to do I don't want them because I me
and my brother that could basically take
us to them all of our rest of our family
is in a different country they got that
but they're being so irresponsible you
need to give them a little punch okay
you know they they really you need to
light them up because you can't make
them do it we'll even if you pay for it
so but you can make them you know feel
really bad for not doing a will which is
what they should feel because there's a
kiddo involved here you take care of
this kid oh mama bear legal forms
dot-com mama bear legal forms calm is
the website very inexpensive online will
state specific to your area and that'll
get it done without spending a whole
bunch of money it's in you you got to do
it you got to stay specific and you got
to do it right now so folks we have done
detailed research you're gonna die
you're not gonna make it out of this
alive and I just watched a video that
our team did of a young couple in
Charleston South Carolina he's 28 years
old sitting on the couch watching TV
with his sweet little wife and fell over
on her dad just had a massive weird
stroke just non predicted nothing no
medical just out of the blue you don't
get to decide this I've never heard
someone say prayed about this and I'm
gonna live a long time I've never heard
someone say that the audacity of that to
which God is up there going say what
what'd you say Oh
what she gets to decide this no you need
a will all of you need a will unless
your child if you're over 18 you need a
will you need a will everyone needs a
will was I unclear